also meine name geht von ungefähr hier
unter den unter den knochen bis hier
unter die brust ca dieses exakt 17
zentimeter ich wurde gleich nach meiner
geburt mit dem hubschrauber in das
herzzentrum leipzig geflogen und wurde
von dem professor dr chris tucker dort
operiert
am offenen herzen den professor ist
hacker haben wir nicht zu gesicht
bekommen
es wurde bloß gesagt dass der professor
post ag operiert und also eine koryphäe
im prinzip auf seinem gebiet ist wissen
sie wie viele stehen habe ich endlich
gestanden tausende das unterschrieben
sind sie durchschnittlich ist eine op
vier stunden
[Musik]
das ist ganz nah beieinander ist
neben rund 100
und machen sie das 34 jahre dann
schaffen sie die marke 10.000 10.000